the physiological PSI is a pattern of
breathing that we all engage in in deep
Sleep When levels of carbon dioxide in
our bloodstream get too high we'll do a
double inhale followed by an extended
exhale you could do it through your
mouth but it works best through the nose
it's inhale
and then you sneak a little bit more air
in at the very end we found in our
laboratory and other Laboratories have
found that just one two or three of
those physiological size brings your
level of stress down very very fast
and it's a tool that you know you can
use anytime the other thing about
breathing and the reason why exhales are
so vital is the following inhales speed
the heart up
when you exhale the opposite is true
anytime you emphasize exhales in other
words making them longer than your
inhales you are slowing the heart rate
down you're calming your system anytime
you emphasize inhales you make them more
vigorous or longer than your exhales
you're speeding up your heart